hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime uproar and today I will
be talking about a crazy black clover
theory about Yami that I'm pretty sure
started out as a joke but with the most
recent events in the manga more and more
people have been hitting me up in the
comments and on Twitter and Instagram
about the possibility of this theory
actually being true this theory involves
alternate worlds and dimensions demons
and dark magic and of course one of my
favorite characters in the entire black
clover series black bull captain Yami
suka hero so I thought it would be a
good idea to explore this theory and its
possible implications of the story in a
special video if you enjoyed the black
clover content on this channel you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell so we know that Yami wasn't born in
the clover kingdom or in any of the
neighboring kingdoms he was born in a
faraway land known simply as the Land of
the Rising Sun which is another way of
saying Japan in our own world Yami was
born as the son of fishermen in the Land
of the Rising Sun and one day when he
was on a fishing boat as a kid he got
caught up in a massive storm and after
some time he washed ashore in the clover
Kingdom when he first found himself in
the clover kingdom Yami faced
difficulties because he did not know the
culture he did not know the language and
he looked different and dressed
different from everyone else people
treated him poorly because he was a
foreigner but Julius Noah chrono who
would later become the wizard King was
impressed with the Ami's dark magic and
the fact that he was a foreigner did not
bother Julius Julius took Yami under his
wing taught him the language of the
clover kingdom and allowed him to join
his magic knight squad at this time
Julius was not yet the wizard king he
was the captain of the azure deer squad
eventually Yami became a powerful magic
Knight and ultimately he became the
magic knight captain of the black bull
squad but a few factors of a Yami have
given rise to the theory that Yami may
not be just a foreigner from another
country but a foreigner from another
world or another
and [ __ ] the first is that Yami appears
to be the only person from the Land of
the Rising Sun in the entire story at
least as far as we know and despite the
fact that he had a life and family back
in his homeland Yami never decided to
return to the Land of the Rising Sun
instead he simply remained in the clover
kingdom in spite of all the difficulties
and discrimination that he faced this
has led some to speculate that Yami
never went back to his homeland because
going back was impossible
the Land of the Rising Sun is actually
the Japan of our own world at some point
in history and during the storm that he
found himself caught up in as a child
Yami will somehow transported to an
entirely different world the world of
black clover Yami cannot return to where
he came from because the portal back to
his world was closed and there is no way
to open it again at least for now many
have also pointed out that Yami's dark
magic is incredibly unique no one else
was born in the world of black clover
has the same type of dark magic as the
army and the fact that he was chosen by
a clover Kingdom grimoire despite being
a foreigner might suggest that Yami is
not from another country in this world
but from another world altogether I
always thought that this theory was a
pretty good joke and I like the idea of
Yami being an Issa Chi protagonist just
at a later stage in his life it's funny
to imagine Yami as a normal Japanese guy
who is transported into another world
there he inherits incredible Opie powers
that he could never have imagined in his
own world and he proceeds to rescue a
bunch of beautiful women like Vanessa
and Charlotte making them part of his
growing Issa Kai protagonists harem and
even though I still think that it's a
pretty good joke I have to admit that
the recent chapters in the black clover
manga have given a lot more credence to
this idea that Yami could actually be
not from another country but from
another world altogether and so I'm
about to examine all of these latest
revelations and all of the clues and
evidence in the story so far in order to
determine whether the theory of Yami
being from another world is actually
possible now from this point on there
will be manga spoilers we're gonna be
looking at the latest revelations in the
black clover story so please proceed
with caution you have
been warned the fact that Yami has such
unique magic and the fact that he is
constantly able to surpass his limits as
if his limits are not of this world are
the perfect starting point for
evaluating this theory in the most
recent arc in the manga the main villain
is a creature known as the devil and
this devil is confirmed to be a creature
from another world another dimension for
hundreds of years this devil has been
trying to find a way to incarnate into
this world and in recent chapters he was
finally able to acquire a body and his
otherworldly devil magic is causing all
sorts of problems for some of the most
powerful characters in the entire series
most types of magic from this world
don't even have any impact on the devil
but Yami's dark magic does have an
effect for some reason the devil cannot
simply block dark magic so he chooses to
dodge it instead apart from dark magic
other forms of magic that appeared to be
somewhat effective against the devil are
asked as anti magic and Patrese demon
light magic which is Magic that he can
use in his Dark Elf form Potteries dark
elf form is the direct result of the
devil's interference and we recently
learned that the demon inside asked his
grimoire the source of Asta's anti magic
is also a devil from the other world
just like the main devil villain that
everyone is currently fighting combine
that with the fact that Yami has an
attack called dark cloaked dimension
slash and you could see how people might
be starting to think that Yami might
also be from another dimension just like
the devil being from another dimension
would explain why Yami is the only
foreigner from the Land of the Rising
Sun in the entire story why he is the
only one with dark magic and why his
magic has an effect on a creature from
another dimension while other types of
magic do not not to mention that Yami is
always able to surpass his limits in
crazy ways and he is able to sense key
the only other person in the black Cobra
kingdom who can use key that we know of
is hasta someone who is always closely
connected to another dimension through
the demon in his grimoire the fact that
both the main villain devil and the
devil inside of Asta's grimoire are
confirmed to be from another world or
dimension proves that other worlds
and dimensions exist and that it is
possible for creatures from one
dimension to appear in another so if we
already know this much can't we also
assume that aside from the dimensions
where the Devils come from other
additional dimensions could exist and
one of these dimensions is where Yami's
homeland is truly located perhaps Yami's
home dimension is actually our own
dimension a world without magic
but once the mysterious storm
transported Yami into the world of black
clover he gained the ability to use
magical powers surpass his limits and
form a harem of beautiful women just
like every good a Sakai protagonist as
things stand this twist would not be
impossible although to be fair whether
or not yamir is from another world or
from the world of black clover doesn't
really change what an awesome character
he is his unique magic and other
abilities like surpassing his limits and
sensing key definitely piqued my
curiosity about his background and it
would be a fun revelation if it turned
out that Yami is from our own world and
that he was just a normal guy without
any magical abilities until he was
transported into the fantasy world of
black clover where he actually received
a grimoire and gained great magical
abilities but whether he is from another
world or not he still had to face
hardship in a foreign land he trained
hard to get to where he is today and he
is one of my favorite mentor characters
in anime period that said the
introduction of other worlds will have a
massive impact on the black lower
storyline moving forward the current
villain the devil is so incredibly Opie
that people have been asking where the
story could possibly go from here ok
let's say that the devil is defeated a
few chapters from now what then since we
now know the truth about the elf
massacre the elves will no longer be
villains and after the devil's
incredible otherworldly power who could
possibly pose a real threat to ask the
you know Yami and the others from what
we've seen so far about the world of
black clover no one in the clover
Kingdom or in the rival Kingdom
surrounding it could possibly measure up
to the devil's power and I say that from
the information that we have so far it
is possible that we will learn more
things about this world and that new
knowledge will open up other
possibilities
perhaps as yet undiscovered ancient
magic will appear or perhaps one of the
Kingdoms has a secret weapon that will
surpass anything we've seen so far and
so the new challenges that our heroes
face after the devil might revolve
around these types of discoveries but
even if the world a black clover doesn't
have anyone or anything that can measure
up to the power of the devil by
introducing the concept of other worlds
and dimensions the black clover manga
kyuki Tabata has created an endless
number of possibilities for future
villains and challenges after all who
knows what else could be going on in the
devil's dimension or what else could be
going on in the countless number of
other potential dimensions that might
exist alongside the two dimensions that
we know about already whatever happens I
am really enjoying the current arc of
the story and I can't wait to see what
Tabata has in store for us next let me
know what you guys think is Yami a
foreigner from a distant land or is he
actually a foreigner from another world
perhaps even our own world also where do
you think that the story will go from
here are we going to get a new villain
from the world of black clover from The
Devil's dimension or from another
dimension that we haven't even seen yet
let me know down in the comments I
always love hearing from you
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more you can leave a like to let
me know and if you're new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell if you'd like to
support more content on the channel and
get some epic anime merch check out our
online store anime out Broadcom we have
original designs that were done
exclusively for us by pro manga artist
Cuusoo mati including this dream big
work hard
hasta shirt for your fan of the channel
feel free to use the discount code
uproar 25 at checkout for an instant 25%
off a huge thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for supporting our work I
want to give a special thank you to our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
and only Gilgamesh chubs is the man and
nothing but a fan and another huge thank
you to our the one tier patrons the ones
who stand above all other clans
including baby Rey ace
Ingrid ah a Lola nod of Maddy Mac and
Michael Calderon if you guys feel that
our content provides value for you and
you want to support more be sure to
check out our patreon link in the
description even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our anime
for patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching I
really appreciate it and until next time
see our space cowboys
[Music]